[Music]
dino here
if you've watched the other videos in
this series you're well on your way to
becoming familiar with apogee edge
and you're seeing how you can begin to
exploit the capabilities of apogee to
further your digital business
you'll be able to continue using apigee
edge for the duration of your evaluation
here are some suggestions for helping
you move forward
first if you'd like to share this
learning experience with your teammates
or colleagues
you can invite other people to your
apogee edge organization
you can work as a team of collaborators
building your api program together
you can explore further by joining us
for a virtual api jam
these are live webcast events check the
events page for details
if you want to further your education
with a more thorough course of training
please visit academy.apigee.com
where we have extensive online
courseware there you can get started on
the path to certification
in case you would like to describe the
capabilities of apigee edge to your
colleagues
we've prepared some materials you can
use for that purpose
finally if you'd like to have a
conversation with an apogee technical or
sales representative
to discuss solution scenarios
architectures
capabilities in more detail our sales
team will be more than happy to help
i hope you've enjoyed this video series
if you have any feedback we'd love to
hear from you on the apogee community
thank you and as always keep it digital